[Musique]
la direction départementale des yvelines
qui assure la couverture de la zone
police nationale sur le sur ce
département c'est à dire environ un
million deux cent mille habitants 1 est
divisé en neuf circonscriptions de
sécurité publique entre mantes les murs
haut conflent sartrouville saint germain
en laye versailles elancourt plaisir et
rambouillet ces neuf circonscriptions
elle
elles ont autorité sur 80 une commune
donc ça fait beaucoup de maires en
contact avec la police nationale
ce partenariat il se fait au quotidien
il se fait
parce qu'il ya une alimentation
régulière soit du maire soin de soi du
commissaire de police sur une
problématique particulière
moi même j'ai demandé à chaque chef de
circonscription de faire chaque mois une
réunion de bilan mensuel lié l'analyse
des statistiques de la délinquance
il est une convention coordination
chaque fois qu'il existe une police
municipale entre la mairie et la police
nationale
si vous voulez il ya un partage de
compétences entre la police nationale et
la police municipale mais dupoux l'idée
c'est que c'est un peu le principe de
subsidiarité c'est que là où les mères
peuvent investir le champ et bien que
les municipalités investissent le champ
pour que la police nationale face à la
délinquance et qui est son domaine de
compétence propre puissent intervenir de
manière efficace sur ce champ là aussi
les maires ils peuvent investir un
chantier notamment celui de la médiation
et ça c'est intéressant et de peut-être
davantage de proximité que là que la
police nationale et dans ce cadre-là la
connaissance du territoire la
connaissance d un des individus et
notamment des leaders
qui peuvent être des leaders positif ou
des leaders négatifs est assez
intéressante
après il ya tous les dispositifs de
prévention auquel participent aussi la
police nationale alors dans les
dispositifs de prévention va également
beaucoup dans les établissements
scolaires
le renseignement territoriales
participent
aux états majors de sécurité le
le renseignement territoriale est en
contact également avec les élus le
donc il ya une relation de
également proximité entre le
les maires leur équipe municipale leur
police municipale et le renseignement
territoriales parce que les
interlocuteurs sont sont identifiés et
cette connaissance de
de l'environnement par le maire qui
connaît ses habitants qui peut qui à
leur tour d'un certain nombre de
problématiques de situations
particulières ça peut être une alerte et
les signalements qui sont faits sont
traités éventuellement par le
renseignement territoriales